[Musique]
vous êtes le boss des bosses pas faux la
désinvolture l'attitude les cuisses en
acier la plus jolie des fiasson
je suis en retard j'étais en train de
rassembler au gluten de la terre pour le
propulser dans l'espace où il pourra
continuer ne rien faire aulnoy l'appel
de ma vie c'est quoi ce délire
je m'appelle câble je viens sur ce gosse
quoi qu'est gosse du pouce ou tu crèves
les enfants nous rendent un peu meilleur
que ce qu'on est
il a besoin de toi ou alors toi tu es
plus futé que j'en nerfs je ne serais
pas capable de tuer ce gamin mais j'y
arriverai pas seul n'a qu'un former un
groupe de la mort qui tue et voilà notre
groupe sera progressiste
paritaire est connue sous le nom de
[Musique]
ex-forces ça sent le réchauffé c'est moi
excellente remarque est maintenant
musique
autre mois d'août ils ont bien chauffé
elle ralentit la justice c'est pas
toujours propre
et si tu veux te battre pour le bien
parfois faute salir les doigts
le sign on pour hommes est à cette
génération ce que la coupe mulet était
aux années 80 ans c'est là que je m'en
veux d'avoir arrêté les études on va
satisfaire les attentes mais genre grave
plus de raison de faire 1 3 on aurait
tort d'essayer bon s'arrête aux deux
essais une tuerie les précédents est
inquiet tendu mais le dernier rapport la
cocaïne est plus réservé seulement la
chatière la cocaïne est produite dans
mon pays mais elle est consommée aux
états unis en dépit de nos meilleurs
efforts de la cocaïne continue à entrer
illégalement dans notre pays et ce de
manière inquiétante
pablo n'a mis que dix à bâtir
l'industrie la plus rentable de toute
l'histoire
je suis la seule journaliste
autorisé à assister à leur premier
congrès et les drogues produite dans
votre pays entre dans merde et cela nous
inquiète
jusqu'où tu comptes à leurs
représentants à la chambre des députés
[Applaudissements]
le ministre de la justice a été
assassinée apport par le président
qu'est ce qui se passe là je n'ai pas de
style sur tout le territoire soit on est
tous copains blâme soit on est aussi
l'ensemble
[Musique]
et on sait tous que signifie la guerre
celui qui a le plus de cash en sort
vainqueur
et entre nous tous ici qui a plus
d'argent
je crois que tu perds la dette
tu n'écoutes pas seul
je vous il devra il vous entraînera vous
le savez très bien aidez nous à
retrouver son monde seulement un
milliard de pesos ces outils vous bouton
vous de profondes pour chaque flic d'ego
mais je payerai 28 euros
[Musique]
maintenant vous allez tous me coûter ma
part il dit
du coup je vais vous des centres en
moto2
sagnes aurait jusqu'à ce que vous
prouviez
on avait entendu nous vivons à paris
dans ses rangs des pontins
t'as fait fortune pablo qu'est ce que tu
veux de plus du respect je cherche le
grand amour
vous cherchez une grande armure non non
ce que je veux c'est l'amour d'une femme
vous voulez le mur d'une ferme
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai dit je veux
faire humour aux comptes
je veux de l'amour je comprends je
voulais des rames en hanoi entre au
passé dieu je n'aime pas les tentacules
papa redressé à force de trop travailler
tu dois prendre des vacances ne plus
occuper des vacances des autres et je
sais comment arranger ça m'évite s'il te
plaît du mois où nous allons une toise
hier oh non non non non non allez il ya
une chose à faire
tu peux faire de la plongée déguster des
mets délicats
ou juste profiter de la vue génial papa
merci beaucoup
quelqu'un pourrait allumer un feu
d'artifice dans ton coeur si ce n'est
pas la croisière s'amuse franck salut la
compagnie je me présente
vous devez être légendaire comte dracula
adouli bout la googlisation mines eu
quelques mots suffisent à un homme pour
briller aux yeux d'une femme par son
intelligence adouli blague ou lydia sion
mines est assurée chérie tu passes tes
vacances comme tu avais raison grand
père valentim les monstres sont
écoeurants il ne se doute pas de ce qui
va leur arriver
tout se déroule comme prévu quelque
chose chez cette femme de m'inscrire ta
confiance
ce plat est mort tellement délicieux
fout ta famille de l'aïe dans le second
cas molle ce n'est pas un poison pour
vous
[Musique]
oui c'était vous nomblot bima vomir à y
résider passe moi ça peut faire plaisir
mais c'était des mères si c'est pas trop
les vacances il ya le couple qui veut
acheter qui revient la fin du mois pour
la contre-visite c'est important tu
penses aux sélections du bien ok et
quand je vous ai frôlé les mômes là ça
serait plus prudent vous apprennent les
bons réflexes très bonne position
moi je pourrais tu apprendras trois
essais
c'est l'oeuf les invités partis bart à
mersch pas bien chercher seulement cinq
vodka grey goose et bleu c'est bizarre
de chicago ouais c'est le gsp
[Musique]
je paye ma phase i
et les ah c'est mon box non non c'est le
prénom de ma mère ouais t'es jalouse ça
y est vu le sens où ça fait mille en
sachant que plus personne que les hommes
sont avec des djeuns mais nous les
femmes on bronze cachée
je pense qu'il peut faire du mal mais on
immobilise projeté ce très bref c'est
pas mal c'était une histoire sa 21e
siècle ça s'appelle des baskets mais
tout gentil mais bon là indycar
pour une fois que tu es pas maltraités
et comptait vraiment dommage de laisser
un homme te faire du bien
on doit plus ici qu'on ait découvert en
fait pas des couleurs plutôt des mails
mother i would like to fait
[Musique]
aussi alors vous êtes en vacances en
famille vous apercevoir avec votre fils
la presby sur toi on s'en amuse gueule
mais je vais pas y arriver moi une
semaine donne moi moi non non non moi
qui m'a parlé d'un truc c'est un truc
facile qu'on pourrait faire mais non ça
mais de toute façon je peux pas je vous
ai dire 70 euros cette recherche menée
pour trois bouteilles de grands crus
classés en poster ce que vous faites là
découlera à prix cassés six ans j'avais
une carte professionnelle
ah oui très bien je connais non non
c'est des gens sérieux sahraouis
saint-émilion 2007 c'est bien ça non moi
je voulais prendre
attendez je voulais prendre un tir de
40% des tiers tu mets moitié du nombre
qui se lit brin trop dangereuse qui
tient effet ces six jours va être tous à
la rue [__] mais tu te mets dans le
crâne ça où l'on me crache convaincront
pour vous tous ces bouffées sans les
commandes à son habitude pays n'est plus
rien
mika ou faut qu on foute la paix qui
comprend son
je vais faire une école à paris et
d'écoles c'est une école de golf vous
entendez la mer faire le guignol est du
maquillage et tout c'est donc une petit
escroc non parce que c'est comme ça que
tu vois toi
enfin petit escroc choix je fais une
dépression
[Musique]
bakou
ouais
et hop
[Musique]
je sais pas si je vais y arriver
toussaint un commando pour coter les
mois
[Musique]
et donc lui vous le connaissez bien je
peux enfin je connais surtout son père
s'était enlevé qu'une punition
je crois qu'il s'en relèvera pas bureau
de monsieur rusk je parle je suis désolé
c'est harold ça n'a pas l'air d'aller à
rome une pure nicheurs
aaron l'avenir c'est cette pilule
d'herbe demain tu t'envoles pour le
mexique
quoi on veut que tu remettre la formule
de la pilule aux labos
[Musique]
ça sympa rf et on vendait notre
production au cartel mais quand on a
arrêté ce sont un peu énervés
il faut le sortir de là rapidement je
connais quelques uns des forces
spéciales expert en extraction
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent une belle
communion quoi en pestant en toi c'est
quoi ça un micro mou faire injecter
beaucoup mais il faut que je puisse vous
suivre
ce n'est pas les élus
vous fait pas peur avec les histoires
sur les gros méchants cartel je sais
comment ça marchera pas au mexique
seigneur tout-puissant croyez vraiment
odieux mais oui naturellement que tu
crois quel genre de personne ne croit
pas en dieu
ben moi j'y crois un peu mais pas tant
que ça
les chevreuils commencé à s'arranger
pour toi fais moi confiance je le sens
bien
ton nom better profession braqueurs
six mois de préparation pour dix minutes
d'action
ok le boss est voir la règle de base est
simple vous serez servi seul pour
neutraliser les gardiens seul pour
percer le coffre mais surtout personne
ne doit vous remettre
c'est le petit nouveau renard
je regarde dans le rétro c'est parti
j'ai mis à sac les plus grandes banques
t
il est de retour
j'ai échappé à tous
[Musique]
t'inquiète tout est sous contrôle et
je sentais bien que tu rejoues ailleurs
au caire
[Musique]
allez on y va qu'elle finirait par des
coureurs
tables identité
[Applaudissements]
si à cela ce n'est des anneaux aux
patrons et aux maisons mères au moins
peuvent une borne t à 8 points
tu étais choisi cartonne j'en suis
toujours convaincu chacun doit être
sauvée levé les mains en l'air et dit
'alleluia' dit je suis un soldat
j'agis
je partirai en plus et heureux parce que
je sais déjà que tu seras là pour
quitter les fidèles
[Musique]
ça concerne également les gens avec qui
j'ai grandi il se soit éloigné du droit
chemin
tu me croit quand je te dis que dieu
veut parler qu'est ce que ça peut faire
ce que tous les autres crohas d'ailleurs
c'est important pour moi
enchères
j'entends dire que j'ai arrêté de croire
à l'enfer des j'ai entendu une voix
chaque être humain a déjà été sinon vous
ne pouvez pas écrire j'aimerais écrire
lire je ne fais que la lyre vous
transmettez la parole de dieu dans cette
église notre dieu aime chacun de nous
pourquoi tu m'as pas bien tu crois pas
que tu me devais sam
je repose la question tu dois réfléchir
à toutes les choses qui sont en jeu pour
toi mais aussi pour son combat en toi tu
n'as pas besoin d'être sauvée pour ça
rien tu peux pas le savoir
tu veux une preuve que c'était pas la
voix de dieu la moitié de ses fils elle
a quitté l'église ça tu vis
[Musique]
tu es avec moi où tu ne mets pas vous
venez nous dire que nous avons tort et
que vous avez raison c'est une doctrine
mensongère que vous battiez
[Musique]
es-tu certaine que c'est la voie du
seigneur que tu as entendu
[Musique]
c'est la première fois de ma vie que je
suis aussi surtout moi et je ne vais pas
abandonner
[Musique]
j'ai encore fait un rêve bizarre la nuit
dernière c'était agréable où est-ce que
tu rêvais de moi j'ai rêvé d'un homme
pauvre message qui changé la vie de
notre ville j'ai très bien vu son visage
merci beaucoup d'être venu les amis et b
g un meeting au bureau avec des
acheteurs à 6h30 et il faut que j'aille
déposer des contrats dallas
tu vas repartis tous ce que vous avez
déjà eu des problèmes de maladies
infectieuses dans le coin
dans la nouvelle ligue si tu ne dis pas
un débit je le ferais on est marié
depuis 19 ans qui partage partage plus
la même vie au partage plus rien
du coup tu en as tu fait un choix
non
il faut qu'on parle à cette offre c'est
lui c'est l'homme que j'ai fait dans mon
rêve
vous c'est commun a besoin de connaître
j'aimerais pourtant le connaître vous
allez voir votre femme et lui redonne
foot rabelais vous vous rendriez
vraiment servait si vous pouviez être un
peu plus gentil que vous voulez mon ami
il va falloir que je réfléchisse à ça
[Musique]
d'où vous venez après la mort de ma
famille le maître m'a mis dans une
petite cabane et qui sait rien gagner de
l'argent j'ai même un peu de respect des
déshérités des sans abri près de chez
vous jette complètement fêlé ou youtube
servir de leurs mains pour travailler il
ya des choses que vous devez savoir sera
j'ai fait beaucoup de mal ce n'est pas
une mauvaise personne et je suis
heureuse d'être
tu es très sexy ce que tu as fait
aujourd'hui sortir avec un sans abri
c'était comment franchement c'est
surprenant
il ya des choses que vous devez savoir
s'ouvre à elle était la seule personne
qui met mais assez pour ne pas laisser
tomber
je t'aime annie rey
[Musique]
que vous soyez riche où que vous soyez
pauvres nous sommes tous et sans abri
nous essayons tous de rentrer chez eux
denver a tout changé nous n'aurions pas
vécu ces moments merveilleux
- une bonne partie des autres membres ça
nous pose un problème que tu ramènes ton
peu pâle des gros ici tu peux lui dire
toi même il ya juste derrière toi
[Musique]
le lycée c'est le fondement du reste de
vos vies parce qu'il faut pas louper sur
la première impression qu'on donne ici
qu'il faut y aller à pompe il y mettre
du coeur et surtout n'entrez pas au
lycée si vous n'avez pas d'appuis il
faut vous vous seriez les coudes pour
survivre pigé une dernière chose
couchez pas avec moins de 5 le lycée
c'est l'occasion se réinventer mama si
tu les changes la romance contre les
cauchemars
[Musique]
les meufs est son marché
d'accord
il vaut mieux être loyal que gagner
comme pas
[Musique]
rue pitt et jolie dis donc et te plaît
j'aime bien les gens sans l'unique
[Musique]
tu sais pas c'est de rester tous les cas
ne prend pas cette vie
c'est ma destinée c'est trop tard
comment on va survivre au lycée
[Musique]
un garçon
est ce que tu pourrais essayé de
m'expliquer ce qu'il fait c'est
compliqué on échoue sa gelée remarquer
freina spl et pas besoin de chance on
est à brentwood rien mal se passe ici
tout bio jay simpson
désolé jamal non c'est bon j'ai aucun
lien avec